todos hemos tenido contacto con las
llamadas corporaciones porque quizás tú
trabajes para una o tal vez le compras
productos a una corporación o tal vez
quizás puede que puedan tengas acciones
con una corporación así que todos
tenemos una noción de lo que es una
corporación pero en este vídeo lo que
quiero hacer es algo más preciso de lo
que es una corporación lo que hace y más
aún porque existen las corporaciones
ahora una corporación una corporación es
una entidad legal es una entidad legal
que puede actuar que puede actuar entre
comillas lo pongo como una persona y
pongo a actuar entre comillas porque hay
cosas que una persona puede hacer una
corporación no como por ejemplo sonreír
ir al parque a no ser debatir también
una corporación no puede hacer eso
cuando digo actuar me refiero a
legalmente una corporación puede
demandar a otra corporación oa una
persona o puede ser demandada por otra
corporación o persona una corporación
puede deber una corporación puede
decirle a otras corporaciones oa una
persona o también puede ser dueño de
algunas cosas a eso me refiero
yo con la palabra actuar ahora una
corporación no puede brincar como una
persona o jajaja reírse como una persona
aunque puede tener un aniversario se
puede entrar una discusión filosófica
pero bueno en lo que yo me quiero
enfocar en este vídeo fuera de lo que es
una corporación es porque existen porque
existen ahora en mi mente tengo dos
hipótesis la primera es responsabilidad
limitada responsabilidad limitada y la
otra mi segunda hipótesis es titularidad
de acciones en amarillo titularidad
titularidad de acciones y claro es
verdad que la corporación puede ser de
varios dueños pueden ellos transferir
acciones entre la gente pueden hacer
intercambios pero en lo que me quiero
enfocar en este vídeo es en la
responsabilidad limitada y me quiero
enfocar aquí porque aún si sólo hay una
persona que es dueña de toda la
corporación aún tiene sentido crearla
justo por la razón de responsabilidad
limitada a ver vamos a hacer un pequeño
ejemplo digamos que aquí tenemos a qué
nombre se les ocurre a gabi aquí tenemos
al cav y aquí está gaby los
activos de gabi ella ella tiene una casa
una casa con un valor de su pongamos
aquí una casa con un valor de 5 millones
de pesos 5 millones y supongamos que
también tiene un buen carro no puedo
decir marcas pero bueno su caro
supongamos que cuesta un millón millón
no mejor no un millón de pesos no es
muchísimo no un medio millón de pesos
medio millón así que medio millón y
digamos que también tiene inversiones
por ahí unas tierras quizás unas cuantas
propiedades que también valen otros
cinco millones y luego camina ella por
la plaza se siente en una banca con un
helado y ve a mucha gente caminar con
bolsas van cargando bolsas porque van a
hacer la comida en su casa así que bueno
ya piensa oye qué tal si hago un negocio
de transporte porque este pueblo lo
requiere así que lo hace va y compra un
vehículo con licencia compra un vehículo
con licencia de hecho comprar un taxi es
algo bastante caro pregunta de la
próxima vez que te subes a un taxi
pregúntale al chófer dile oiga don
cuánto le costó qué onda con la licencia
y todo eso esa
muy muy caro pero supongamos supongamos
que aquí a gabi le costó 800 mil pesos
800 mil pesos y que también le compro
seguro supongamos que al menos por este
año le compro seguro un seguro de no sé
cien mil pesos y gaste un seguro porque
ya sabes dice bueno quizás algo malo
suceda algo malo puede pasar quizás
atropello a alguien y me demandan así
que ella obtiene un seguro de
responsabilidad este es un seguro de
responsabilidad y digamos que es una
póliza de pensemos que es algo optimista
y piensa esta chica piensa que nadie la
puede demandar por algo más de 100 mil
pesos así que ella dice bueno es una
póliza de 100 mil pesos póliza de 100
mil pesos y bueno ella ella ya tiene su
vehículo entonces ella sale en su taxi
levanta personas las deja en su casa
pero un día de repente por accidente
ella rueda sobre el pie de alguien o no
hoy qué feo entonces bueno más aún para
su mala suerte el pie de esta persona no
es alguien no
o sea es es un jugador de fútbol un
jugador de fútbol
entonces le destroza el pie este jugador
de fútbol super reconocido le arruina su
carrera este hombre así que aquí tenemos
al jugador de fútbol y bueno tenemos
este jugador su carrera termina ahí dice
o no mi carrera en lugar de decir o no
mi pie se preocupó por su carrera y
bueno de hecho bueno sí claro ahora
demanda a gabi la demanda lo voy a poner
aquí lo voy a escribir porque es un dato
muy importante lo que hizo pobre
muchacha demanda al ghab y demanda a
gabi por un millón de pesos un millón de
pesos lo demanda porque la ruina la
carrera y bueno creo que es un millón de
pesos queda corto si consideramos que
era un jugador mundial y bueno la corte
le dice bueno pues linda le arruinaste
el pie a la cuba este a este jugador no
sabes manejar pasaste muy muy cerca de
la banqueta qué sé yo le dice mil cosas
así que la corte está en en el lado del
jugador y ahora acabe y tendrá que pagar
el millón de pesos tendrá que malbaratar
su casa tendrá que vender sus propias
de propiedades también tendrá que
malbaratar todo y ahora ya solamente
tiene solamente se ahora ella ella les
da esto no porque se lo tiene que dar
tiene que vender eso se los da al
jugador o el dinero que saca de ahí y
ahora tiene solamente un coche y un taxi
así que tenemos que el negocio de tener
un taxi no le funciona del todo gastó
los 800 mil pesos y no le sacó mucho
dinero simplemente la dejó escasa ahora
lo que ella tiene que haber hecho y
tiene que haber creado una corporación
separada una corporación separada
llamada quizás con el nombre de servicio
de transporte servicio de transporte
gaby link y transferir suficiente dinero
para que el carro la licencia y el
seguro le pertenecieron a esta entidad
legal a esta corporación
aquí tendrías el taxi el taxi más la
licencia del taxi así que serían 800 mil
pesos serían transferidos a la
corporación y la corporación lo hubiera
comprado el nombre de la corporación
recuerda que ellos pueden actuar como
personas pueden comprar cosas en su
nombre
el dueño de este auto sería servicios de
transporte gaby inc no gabi y también
compraría en el seguro de 100 mil pesos
ahora un seguro un seguro para un taxi
es algo bastante caro y ellos son dueños
de ese auto ellos un hoyo del seguro de
todo esto así que bueno también
recordemos que son 100 mil pesos de
seguro de responsabilidad y bueno muy
bien ahora veamos la situación desde
otro ángulo el taxi ruedas sobre el pie
del jugador su pie se destroza ya no
puede jugar fútbol y demanda al dueño
del taxi pero ahora el dueño del taxi ya
no es esta chica
el dueño del taxi es servicio de
transporte es gabino así que los demanda
demanda servicios de transporte es gabi
hay que dejar claro que con esta
realidad los activos de gabino
incluirían el vehículo ni el seguro
ahora lo que incluye ser 100% dueña de
servicio de transporte es gabi 100%
dueña de servicios de transporte así que
el activo es ahora el ser 100% dueña de
esto pero esto es una entidad legal
separada entonces el jugador ahora demás
está esta entidad los demanda por un
millón de pesos la corte le dice hey tú
debes a este jugador un millón de pesos
no le puedes y que no sabe manejar
porque una corporación maneja pero
desafortunadamente para el jugador y
afortunadamente para la chica gabi de
hecho aquí es donde vamos con
responsabilidad limitada aquí aquí vamos
a ver lo que realmente es la corporación
puede vender esto de aquí el taxi y
también recibir los 100 mil pesos del
seguro así que reciben los 100 mil y de
esta manera sólo le podrá dar al jugador
900 mil pesos 900 mil pesos y claro la
corporación la corporación irá a
bancarrota esta corporación ir a
bancarrota y pues así sucede esto es van
a bancarrota así que esto de lo que
javier adueña la corporación a lo que ya
podía decir que valía 900 mil pesos 900
mil pesos ahora vale 0 ya no tiene valor
esto vale 0 lo tachamos adiós
el jugador ya no puede ir tras ninguna
otra cosa ni siquiera atrás del dueño de
la corporación no puede ir atrás de
ellos si la corporación no tuviera un
seguro suficiente o si esto fuera como
un negocio personal si esta corporación
no fuera no tuviera una cuenta bancaria
entonces quizás así el acorde le dejaría
saber el jugador que puede buscar más a
fondo que puede llegar tras los dueños
de la corporación pero ese no fue el
caso mientras esta corporación estuviera
razonablemente capitalizada el jugador
no puede ir tras otra cosa que no sea la
corporación solamente puede ir tras la
corporación entonces como tú puedes ver
gaby esta chica aquí tenía la
responsabilidad limitada limitada lo más
que podía perder mientras corriera este
servicio de transporte adecuadamente
mientras tuviera suficiente seguro y
tuviera suficiente dinero en él mientras
tuviera todo bajo el control correcto lo
más que podía perder en el valor de la
organización así que haga lo que haga
corporación mientras esté haciendo todo
lo legal correcto así atropella a
alguien o lo que sea no puede
demandar a los dueños y eso es la razón
número uno por la que las personas
tienen corporaciones por la
responsabilidad limitada